bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france or la cour suprême de
facebook qui contredit les décisions du
réseau social une première action
oui c'est une décision très intéressante
parce que ce conseil de surveillance
dévié par facebook par mark zuckerberg
lui-même est censée organiser
réglementer la question de des contenus
des sites sur internet et des décisions
qui convient de prendre tel que par
exemple le bannissement du comte de
donald trump
donc il est très intéressant que cet
ovni juridique cette commission ce
conseil suprême indépendant de facebook
les dévié par facebook des six que les
quatre parmi les syndicats qui ont été
soumis posent difficulté et cela montre
justement l'importance voire même la
nécessité impérieuse de réglementer la
question de la diffusion des contenus et
des profils sur les réseaux sociaux
alors un organe indépendant mais très
par facebook
oui c'est très intéressant car facebook
cela fait déjà de nombreuses années et
bénéficie de toute l'espèce d'actualité
juridique tant en france qu'aux états
unis grâce au premier amendement
et cela fait pour autant d années que
les pouvoirs publics demandent au réseau
social comme facebook de réglementés
c'est-à-dire d'organiser la question des
contenus de licéité des contenus et de
la super équipe méconnue en ligne et ce
faisant il a fallu attendre de plus de
dix ans pour que facebook créé une sorte
d'organisme lui même puisque les
pouvoirs publics ne l'ont pas fait
facebook de manière spontanée et avec de
bonne foi je dirais faut lui reconnaître
cela a décidé de constituer ce conseil
pour réglementer la question de la
diffusion des contenus et de se
soumettre d'arbitrer les
les problèmes que facebook peut avoir
pour supprimer tel ou tel contenu ou tel
ou tel profil alors oui donc c'est un
organe on répète qui a été créé par
facebook lui-même dans le but de l'aider
à modérer les contenus mis en ligne
c'est un bon constat de départ mais
finalement est-ce que c'était à facebook
de se doter lui-même dental organes
c'est vrai qu'il est très particulier de
constater que facebook facebook lui-même
se dote d'un organe indépendant pour
s'auto contrôler laisser comme
j'oubliais vous l'indiquez parce que les
pouvoirs publics ils auront passé et
surtout parce que les pouvoirs publics
sont dans l'incapacité de le faire
en effet il faut bien garder à l'esprit
que internet est un outil de
communication qui dépasse les frontières
ou les frontières n'ont plus lieu les
territoires non plus et on voit bien que
la france comme les états unis ne
peuvent pas réglementé s'agissant
d'internet puisqu'ils ne peuvent pas
d'en avoir d'emprise sur des sites qui
sont dans un état étranger et donc il
est essentiel que les réseaux sociaux
eux-mêmes s'organise en ayant conscience
de leur importance et c'est justement de
dans cette conscience de cette
importance que facebook a supprimé le
compte de donald trump
parce que des hommes politiques
utilisent les réseaux sociaux à des fins
politiques pour détourner l'opinion
détourner les suffrages et il se jouait
de l'opinion donc il est important à un
moment donné que les réseaux sociaux
prennent conscience de leur importance
du poids qui est peu avant dans
l'opinion et près les décisions qu'elle
est tout un public ne sont pas capables
de tout en prenant créé en pratique
alors c'est donc à ce même conseil un à
qui il reviendra de décider s'il faut
rouvrir au pas le compte de donald rang
pour revenir sur ce dossier cette
affaire qui a fait beaucoup beaucoup de
bruit est ce que cela vous a choqué que
facebook décide tout seul de fermer le
compte d'un président en exercice il en
faut bien une première
c'est tombé sur donald trump si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi
en effet c'est la première fois que
facebook décident de passer à l'action
pour prendre une décision aussi radicale
à l'écart d'un président de la
république c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire que cet événement se passe
peut être qu'elle a viré les
susceptibles de se reproduire
en tout état de cause il faut constater
que facebook se comporte pas comme elle
l'hébergeur de connu mais comme lead un
éditeur de contenus puisque il contrôler
le contenu qui est diffusé en gardant la
possibilité pour un candidat de
continuer s'exprimer s'agissant du cas
de donald trump
il faut bien relever que donald trump a
appelé à la violence sur le réseau
social a provoqué à la violence que l'on
connaît à savoir l'intrusion dans le
sénat dans le congrès et les actes de
violence auxquels on a pu assister
facebook a donc pris la décision certes
politique mais qui je pense était
nécessaire compte tenu de la gravité de
la situation et du comportement de
donald trump lui même chose qu'aucun
autre président la république je serais
permis par ailleurs anthony même merci à
vous rappelle que vous êtes avocat au
barreau de paris et spécialiste
numérique merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur arte